maintenant j'en arrive à passer quelque
chose de très sérieux
vas-y ouais je suis prêt c'est l'anti
portrait chinois
ah j'adore ça
[Applaudissements]
voilà jean marie bigard et bouger ouais
si vous étiez un défaut la gentillesse
ouais mais c'est un super défaut ça on
n'est pas à l'abri d'ailleurs de la
gentillesse des autres si vous étiez une
injure allez tous vous faire [ __ ]
sale mérite d'être clair mais si vous
étiez une maladie une maladie
je serai peut-être la maladie ah oui je
serai la maladie de gilles de la
tourette tu connais ce mardi j'ai vu ça
l'autre jour c'est extraordinaire si ea
mais qui parle normalement
ouais c'est comme un tick tock je suis
grâce à peine et tout d'un coup le mec
sort une insanité quoi ouais c'est
charles avec lui tu dis bah thierry
j'aime bien ton émission va te faire
[ __ ] connard
mais il ya on voit pas assez souvent
laurent baffie travaille avec eux
continuent à parler normalement vous
aussi elle veut y meurt c'est pas mal
ouais d'ailleurs tu sais que robinson
crusoé sur la fin de sa vie il avait la
maladie d'alzheimer ah bon tu sais
comment ils appelaient vendredi
non l'autre jour
[Applaudissements]
jean marie bigard si vous étiez un
accident je suis un accident mais oui si
vous étiez une perversion je suis une
perversion mais qui parce que ça va s'y
enchaînent si vous étiez une guerre je
serai la guerre des boutons ce que la
guerre maintenant c'est avec des boutons
baril et puis elle se fait
économiquement il des boutons tu vois
bien chirurgicale et prop soi-disant
réchauffer trop content quand un mec sur
un bouton un bon père de famille dit bon
l'embargo au godinand l'embargo mais il
appuie sur un bouton et ils tuent à
coups sur 3500 personnes par jour par
exemple embargo sur l'irak a tué un
million et demi de personnes dont cinq
cent mille enfants de moins de cinq ans
simplement toi ici et bien aligné toi ça
cent mille enfants toi là j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de minutes de silence pour ça
non mais un embargo ça tue à coup sûr et
puis bon bah voilà donc c'est là que ça
serait vraiment la guerre des boutons
qui détient une arme je serai excalibur
si j'étais une arme
déjà parce qu'elle sait pas tirer pas
tout le monde comme d'hab il remarquer
et ainsi lui c'est bientôt servir tu
peux pourfendre un certain nombre de
gros cons avec excalibur challes
excalibur
oh
si vous étiez une cicatrice cicatrices
chalet la cicatrice de de l'appendicite
parce que c'est pas loin de la salle des
fêtes
si vous étiez un poison
je serai une femme ouais
aliot
[Applaudissements]
tj d'houdain samatan quand on en bouffe
avec des amis je me tourner vers ma
femme et j'ai dit tais toi toi mal
baisées
et grâce à qui ça veut dire à toi chez
rue balore puis ceux qui commandent
ah justement si vous étiez une [ __ ]
jusqu'à une chaque genre béatrice dalle
tu vois ouais parce que j'adore béatrice
1 c'est pas ça la question au contraire
même ils adorent super mais maintenant
plus entière et aussi parce que c'est
non je dis je dit béatrice dalle parce
que c'est le type de fille qui est
d'ailleurs de cordialement détesté par
les autres femmes certainement parce que
c'est vrai que tu as envie de grimper
dessus et tu sais que tu vas jamais y
arriver et donc c'est très fantasmatique
si vous étiez un dictateur
charlie chaplin si vous étiez un
assassin rocco siffredi je serai
parce que c'est une idée de film que
j'espère c'est que je dis ça c'est un
choix un serial buteur mais qui tuerait
des blondes à coups de beats l'homme
rechercherait dans toute la france là
bas ça si vous étiez une torture
une torture un truc pire que jean pierre
foucault un jeu c'est pas le jeu serait
un vélo un vélo c'est une torture la
preuve les ils sont obligés de prendre
de la drogue pour monter dessus c'est
pour te dire que c'est dur c'est quand à
vélo la sueur du coneil vélo truqueur we
will élever nos frontières
et oui c'est le vélo que michel walker a
mis en vente pour michaëlle jean
comme lui
c'est génial ça c'est pour le métal
blanc michel lemay tu vois rien demandé
à moi bah tu peux donner ce que tu veux
un dunk claudia n'ont peut-être pas mais
non mais qu'est ce que je vais te donner
a fléchi
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
non
[Applaudissements]
la tente orange euros
alors
des maîtresses la table que ce soit des
caméras cachées soient les caméras et le
cpo michael alors pour le micro je fais
comment battu non mais le slip sais pas
c'est pas suffisant tiens tu sais tu
sais dit c'est que depuis bercy
je ne quitte pas si chaud sur wii est-ce
que c'est elle qui sont rentrés devant
les 13000 d'un sauna et bain je donne
les chaussures et le sait le slip arabe
[Applaudissements]
et bon week end
bélanger
tout est la bienvenue pour victor
[Applaudissements]
pour muscler
merci d'y aller
michael si tu seras pas de cabanes avec
ça
voilà les libéraux
[Applaudissements]
je trouve ça vachement bien que gasquet
a réussi le sortir de là parce que mais
qui lie à perpète
la police allègue il a pris 22 ans pour
avoir tué six gonzesses et lui pour un
peu de shit il est à perpète donc si on
arrive à faire bouger seuil si tu y
arrives et ben ça vachement bien parce
que ça va faire école bah ouais il
faudrait que chirac nous aide un peu
aussi un oiseau allez vas-y jacqueline
un jacques un civil est il mort
je serai une petite mort c'est la petite
mort ouais la petite bord que tu as vu
dans les yeux de sa femme quand il l'a
fait jouir à coup en 69
c'est vrai que sa jambe allait bien
leur bonheur
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus